how do we deal with criticism you talk
about criticism in the book
as someone whose platform is growing now
this is something that personally for me
is a
a really important thing i'm starting to
garner sufficient traffic that criticism
comes
thick and fast how can i deal with it
yeah so old dad joke guy goes to the
doctor
and uh said the doctor says uh you got
trouble your heart's going to
give out in a few weeks he says i want a
second opinion
and the doctor says okay you're ugly too
and
the thing is i would value the doctor's
opinion on the first thing
but on the second none of his business
none of his business
because you're in a relationship with
someone who doesn't think you're ugly
the fact that the doctor thinks you're
ugly is irrelevant
so the key here is that
all criticism is not the same just
because someone
found two earbuds and listened to your
podcast doesn't mean you care about
their opinion
it may very well be that they should
listen to somebody else's podcast
you're not trying to be joe rogan so if
they want to listen to joe rogan they
should go over there
if they start saying you need to do
these things to be more like joe rogan
so i'll like you you need to say
joe rogan's over there and that
was a huge lesson for me to figure out
who are we seeking to serve where is the
smallest viable audience and how do i
ignore everyone else so
15 years ago i took comments off my blog
and there was an outcry
this is not a real blog there's no
comments don't you care blah blah
i realized if i left the comments on
i was going to write every blog post a
little bit longer explaining myself a
little bit more
trying to get rid of any place for
someone to criticize me
and eventually i'd have no blog so i had
a choice blog with no comments
or no blog and i got rid of the comments
and 10 years ago
i stopped reading the reviews on amazon
haven't read one ever since
and my writing has gotten better not
worse because
a one-star review doesn't tell me i did
a bad job it tells me the wrong person
read my book
i love that i also think that it ties in
a lot
with enacting whatever you feel
is true to yourself in creativity
because if it's something that is
genuinely
unmolested from what you want to do to
its creation
you don't second-guess it i think
criticism
probably strikes at people who are
playing this meta game or perhaps being
a hack or
20 hack 50 hack whatever particularly
harshly
yes now there's something that goes with
this that's super important
which is just because it's what you
wanted to do
doesn't mean it's guaranteed to work
those are two separate things
right so if you want to compose a
symphony that's plated entirely on raw
pieces of fish
please do but do not expect the
commission from the london symphony
orchestra they're different things
and so part of what we do as a creator
is we
we've got to figure out who do we seek
to change what change do we seek to make
and then we have to make it for those
people
those people are the ones who are
seeking to change
not necessarily ourselves if it's a
hobby that's different but if it's
professional work
you're not allowed to hate your customer
you're not allowed to hate your fan
because you're there for them just as
much as you need them to be there for
[Music]
you